and I feel like I'm oversimplifying
right I mean it do I ever get there do I
ever get to this minimalist life no no I
mean I don't think so I'm almost there
dude
I'm so close what I've realized is that
yes you'll get somewhere that you want
it to be but there's always gonna be
somewhere else you want to be and thank
goodness for that right like I feel
really happy that we're living here in
Los Angeles now we've got a beautiful
studio set up I'm really happy with the
apartment that I live in you know you're
happy with your new apartment the year
in and this works really well for right
now but it does mean it doesn't mean
that we won't want to change some point
in the future
yeah and circumstances are guaranteed to
change yes like there's that absolutely
so minimalism you know when I eat when I
first saw it it was never a destination
for me it was it was like this common
sense philosophy that I was like oh like
I just need to apply these principles to
my life and maybe I can regain some of
that control right but yeah anything
could be taken too far right what yes
yeah I mean I think that if if if it's
reactionary the thing we were talking
about earlier we were doing the YouTube
pre-roll thing acting versus reacting
and maybe that's the question that the
Sarah is trying to figure out here is if
she reacting to the job but does that
make her want to move away or is she
wanting to take action because that's
the appropriate next step in in her life
yeah you know when it comes to
simplifying and her talking about how
she's kind of become addicted to it or
maybe she's like overdoing it you know
just to reiterate like you can take
anything and and overdo it she even
talks about you know she the word
obsession she used in her question an
obsession can be a really beautiful
thing yeah
really can be it until it becomes
compulsive right right yeah yeah I mean
in fact you know I think that you
we often get confused and we think
removing the clutter is is the end
result but you and I sometimes talk
about how it's really just the first
step you're you're getting rid of the
excess so you can make room
for your health or your finances or your
creativity or your career or your
ability to contribute you're making room
for those things that's the point that's
the purpose of simplifying there are
other benefits like it's nice you feel
calm in your own home it's nice to get
the excess stuff out of the way you feel
better coming home to an intentionally
curated home absolutely but that is not
the point just the the simplifying so
ask yourself why not just the how to
side of things well the cool thing for
Sarah is so she has minimized her life
up to this point to the point where mate
you know she's talking about maybe she's
taking it too far but the cool thing is
is that if she does need to pick up and
move she could do that very easily yeah
and that's what I appreciate about like
Mariah and those possessions and what we
have in our lives is physical things
it's it's the right amount moving always
sucks but it's easier when you're I
can't turn my life around on a dime
it's it's it's really does it's really
freeing the part of the reason you could
turn your life around on a dime is
because you're untethered from those
expectations as well where it's like
well now I'm gonna live here for the
rest of my life and I'm gonna have this
particular career for the rest of my
life and I'm going to have a family it
looks like this for the rest of my life
no you're not tethered to that you're
tethered you're untethered which is
freeing so that you can explore as your
preferences desires personality changes
over the years which it should yeah so I
think Sara should get clear on those
preferences and if she wants to leave
New York that's okay but instead of
running from New York she really has to
be clear on what she's running towards
so Sara maybe it's time to graduate from
New York City and that's okay yeah yeah
I'm gone away you can go back if you
does you ever make the wrong decision
and that's the thing you and and
hopefully at the end of this I'm gonna
talk about some of my favorite cities
and why there's some of my favorites and
and what I'm realizing with Sara here is
you're gonna make some sort of decision
you know and you may not be the perfect
decision but whatever the decision is
you're gonna learn from it the important
thing is to take some sort of action
to move beyond the situation that's
comfortable right now and that's what
kept me where I was for a long time I
was sixty percent comfortable everything
was six out of ten it's like well I
don't want to feel any real pain I don't
want this to be a 2 or a negative 2 or a
negative 5 experience so I'm gonna stay
here in my comfort zone but after a time
that comfort zone becomes unsettling it
becomes uncomfortable because we're no
longer growing we're not being the best
version of ourselves and then what we
desire is no longer being that
you